hola qué tal cómo están bienvenidos a
este programa especial en facebook live
lo prometido es deuda ya le habíamos
hablado la semana pasada del jueves
pasado en el castor cibernético de que
íbamos a tener este programa especial en
facebook live en el que contábamos en el
que contamos de hecho con la
participación de un invitado
especialista en derechos humanos
inmigración y refugiados la idea es que
bueno conversar un poco con él y si
ustedes tienen sobretodo preguntas que
hacernos sobre la inmigración sobre el
refugio sobre los derechos humanos aquí
en canadá él es la persona indicada para
eso stewart es banfi como decíamos
abogado especialista en derechos humanos
inmigración y refugiados
muchas gracias por haber aceptado la
invitación y bienvenido a radio canadá
internacional y este facebook live
y bienvenido a todos ustedes allá cuya
idea de este facebook live es que las
personas que se cuestionan sobre la
inmigración y el refugio aquí en canadá
puedan hacer las preguntas a stewart
aquí directamente así que no lo duden
hagan sus preguntas leonardo está al pie
del cañón con la con la computadora
todas las preguntas me las va a ir
pasando así de que no pierdan tiempo
vamos a comenzar entonces con stewart
stewart tú tienes una larga trayectoria
como abogado en inmigración y refugio de
acuerdo a tu experiencia stewart qué
tipo de inmigrantes llegan a canadá
esa es la gran pregunta y no es fácil
contestar en este momento a partir de
los años 90 funcionalmente ser gente con
dinero gente con muchos estudios y gente
que tenía capas de las técnicas que se
buscan aquí en canadá
históricamente hemos puesto más peso en
cuestiones de unificación familiar y de
traer padres y abuelos y miembros la
familia por eso cambió mucho a para que
los años momentos ya entonces cuáles son
los requisitos stewart para emigrar a
canadá las personas que nos están
escuchando en este momento se preguntan
qué tengo que hacer yo o algo así para
emigrar a canadá cuáles son los
requisitos uno puede llegar como
inversionista hay que tener más o menos
800.000 dólares nada más no poder dejar
por lo menos 5 años
puede venir como empresario aunque es en
categoría que al menos menos grande
puede ver como trabajador especializado
o gente con muchos estudios en varios
temas que son muy adaptables y que van a
poder hacer una buena vida que más o
menos también a toda la categoría de
gente que pueden ser pagados por
familiares aquí por esposos o por otros
familiares pensados y el perfil de las
personas que vienen stewart es que son
familias con niños son hombres o mujeres
solteros casados cuál es el perfil
decidí siempre me contestar con
exactitud
es gente con
o dos o tres diplomas
de gente que tiene la experiencia de
negocio o capacidades tácticas fuertes
gente que pueden tener impresiones
importantes
o gente que esté en mi familia aquí
el gran cambio que sí son otros 20 años
de publicar una inmigración económica y
no la inmigración familiar
el gobierno de steve harper fue muy
antiguo refugiado y / humanitario y todo
el lado humanitario y derechos humanos
refugiados ha bajado todos los años
aunque entonces pero ahora en la digamos
que entre las personas que pueden venir
también se encuentran refugiados
canadá está aceptando refugiados ahora
de hecho se aceptaron el año pasado
35.000 refugiados sirios
[Música]
el canadá es un país que escoge
refugiados el mundo entero y puede
traerlos aquí los programas para traer
los refugiados para el programa público
que es el gobierno que está financiando
llegado a los refugiados aquí
y privado donde son cinco personas de
iglesias grupos comunitarios que pueden
fallar refugiados y hace un programa
donde la sociedad canadiense se implica
a caminar refugiados
el gobierno también fallas cifras más o
menos altos
es más el rosa que muchos otros países
el gobierno de harper no les gusto
estaba engordando los cifras el año
pasado a futuro después de ser elegido
fueron muchos sitios pero los cifras
globales no han aumentado mucho en ese
año así que no sabemos exactamente la
posición del gobierno actual con
respecto a la nueva a la nueva población
de refugiados que puede hacer tarde pero
hay que entender que hay refugiados que
llegan que pide el refugio
los que quieran llegar al verdadero
refugio nos han puesto muchos obstáculos
perdidas de aquí han puesto a gente
fuera genera en los aeropuertos para
averiguar
los pasó por tres la gente que todo el
avión
ha hecho muchos problemas por tener
vicios porque no se prodiga hasta aquí
han puesto muchos trabajos para poder
del fútbol dentro de la verdad de la
frontera si uno pasa por ustedes niños
dicen que es súper seguro y que no se
puede pedir
no la frontera hubo un gran combate
contra los refugiados sobre todo va a
jugar propia bien pues algunas
justamente stewart o están mencionando a
eeuu en este momento ha habido cambio en
la presidencia de eeuu el nuevo
presidente de donald trump
ya se pronunció y dijo que va a expulsar
a todos los ilegales de eeuu piensas tú
que pueda haber una ola de refugiados de
eeuu hacia canadá
mi opinión es que
si es posible pero no van a ser todos
los refugiados cuando se hablen ilegales
los extranjeros son más bien gente que
son migrantes económicos hay refugiados
programa de seguridad sean más bien
migrantes económicos que los refugiados
generalmente cuando tenían que escoger
entre canadá estados unidos
la primera que por ejemplo va bien es
cierta preferencia y por canadá porque
canadá no es el imperio y no está
vinculado con los gobiernos represores
en las américas
así que si van a ver más
de decir que todo es excelente para
llegar aquí lo creo
tampoco creo que trampa poder deportarlo
a todos los tampoco si va a ser difícil
esa tarea no hay estados los los
aullidos que están sufriendo
tremendamente el material futuro porque
ya no tiene
la política de trump es una política
a la escasez de mano de obra quizá lo va
a obligar incluso a legalizar los que
están de ilegales
es una campaña basado en el miedo basado
en la
xenofobia
su selección es el resultado algo que le
da la victoria bueno entonces bueno y
les pedimos ustedes allá del otro lado
de la cámara stewart está aquí
justamente para responder a sus
preguntas aquí leonardo me está pasando
el teléfono con algunas preguntas
césar rodríguez jarr y de bogotá
colombia
él dice pregunta personal en la página
de inmigración de canadá no he logrado
los puntos necesarios a pesar de mi
francés y de estudios de magíster parece
que es por no estar casado y no tener
hijos
he aplicado en varias páginas de trabajo
pero tampoco he sido llamado que me
recomienda no soy refugiado gracias a
mejor
oferta de trabajo aquí
si faltan los puntos los dos donde uno
puede tener más puntos con ofertas de
trabajo de hacer una visita que acaba la
s que pidieron a dice que alguien sin
venir aquí mirar al mercado el trabajo y
ver cómo acumular los puntos necesarios
pero tú si crees que él desea emigrar de
que el gobierno canadiense o sea la
embajada de canadá en bogotá le dé una
visa de turista para venir acá a hacer
una prospección eso es muy impredecible
de verdad son los peores países del
mundo
y si ellos creen no tiene vínculo con su
propio país para quedarse allí no son
fáciles para realizar por si uno tiene
trabajo y tiene estudios y tiene razones
se realiza pero canadá es un país
sumamente difícil porque es mucho más
fácil era mucho más fácil históricamente
regido por los eeuu
pero si eres soltero es profesional
tiene estudios y les gustaría emigrar
pero de acuerdo con lo que él dice no no
ve como
yo no conozco su expediente pero poder
operar más es muy difícil aquí
quienes llegan más stewart a canadá los
profesionales e inmigrantes
profesionales o trabajadores
especializados
los dos teniendo la colombia colombia es
un país donde la gente bien educada en
los mejores economías de la primera que
gente bien trabajadora hombres negocios
de alto nivel
es un país que nunca está bien abierto a
la educación como puede tener
a los que llegan aquí
en parte depende donde hay la embajada
llamada canadiense y la facilidad con lo
cual uno puede someter su caso es seguro
que más hacen por usar el bogotá méxico
donde hay una embajada que estoy
viviendo los los pedidos
y es muy difícil la parte del centro
américa donde la ola de violencia
increíble
en nuestro oyente césar habla del
sistema de puntaje como para los que no
entienden para los que no saben cuál es
ese sistema cómo funciona el sistema de
punta
aquí es complicado para explicar en
pocas palabras pero generalmente te van
a dar tantos puntos para un primer
diploma después de la escuela secundaria
tanto por el segundo tanto por el
tercero
para dar 2.2 pruebas
unos años de trabajo en tu campo
laverdad.es otros idiomas que uno puede
hablar
cercas a base de puntos si tienes niños
más joven que ciertos puntos
pueden dar puntos aprovechó
adaptabilidad si ellos creen que el
idioma me imagino también el idioma sí
por supuesto que los 12 idiomas inglés y
francés de los puntos
es el sistema supuestamente objetiva
para analizar la posibilidad de éxito de
la persona cuando llegan aquí
stewart hay prejuicios que vinculan a la
inmigración o el refugio diciendo que
les cuesta caro al sistema recibir
tantos inmigrantes o recibir tantos
refugiados es cierto que los inmigrantes
se representan un peso económico para
canadá
se colocó al pensarse de migración en
carrera el nombre el proyecto el peso
económico
es un país que depende mucho la
inmigración así uno mira lo que pasaron
los últimos 34 40 años atrás y no veis
bien abiertas y eliminación hemos tenido
el crecimiento económico tampoco mejor
que lo que hay en el oeste de europa o
en los de los niños
no es pues seguro que el país es mucho
mejor dirigido que sus países
uno de los puntos positivos más fuertes
de calidad es aperturas el inmigración
yo no puedo pensar que al emigraciones
empezó a que es algo
más o menos que es el elementos
dinámicos de nuestra economía no es el
elemento de peso mientras no se puede
hacer una relación de causa-efecto y
decir que la inmigración o los
refugiados viven del bienestar social
por ejemplo
no es la verdad del cielo pero
hay gente que lo dice
de la misma opinión de trump en este
país también
falsos rumores y falsas historias en
calidad diciendo que los refugiados los
cuestan caro la verdad es que si uno
llega aquí como refugiado los primeros
años son difíciles pero después de cinco
o seis años para llegar a este nivel es
bastante parecido a país de donde
llegaron por la diferencia entre el
refugiado que llega a canadá y el
migrante económico es que es mucho más
probable que los refugiados se quede
aquí que fue una familia aquí que
construye la economía canadiense
el inmigrante económico
se da cuenta el que cábala no es el
paraíso que ha vendido antes de venir y
ponerse en australia por eso en europa
en los eeuu en el país donde más dinero
los refugiados generalmente se quedan
generalmente y entonces lo que entiendo
de lo que me dices stewart es que hay
muchos que llegan aquí y se van
así que si tú quieres hacer dinero
hasta muy recientemente era mejor que
los audios que en canadá
si tú quieres tener la paz pero na vida
tranquila tener que estar un país donde
los niños pueden tener una aplicación
probase escoger canadá de planes es el
dinero la calidad de vida que uno busca
es cada uno cree sus propias prioridades
y hay una pregunta que a stewart que hay
alguien que nos dice es hay sorteos para
ser seleccionado o es por mérito porque
según esta persona se habla de sorteos
es una mezcla
tienes que someter el expediente no le
vas a acumular sus mentes de puntos
teniendo esos puntos que pueden poner en
el tipo de sorteo que se hace cada mes
también hay gente que busca traer sus
padres y sus abuelos
no quieren abrir el cupo tan grande
precedente para el sorteo que se hace
más o menos cada tres meses pero es algo
muy nuevo así que no no puede evaluar
cómo funciona bien lo que supuestamente
es más mérito
dos años más en los sorteos y es una
política de la nueva administración de
los liberales o ya existía en el tiempo
de los conservadores conservadores
cambiaron el sistema en donde tú tienes
que satisfacer cierto nombre de puntos
por tener la posibilidad de estar
adentro del sistema que te pueden
ofrecer la inmigración
a cada mes o cada dos besos porque ya
hay otra pregunta es
stewart para atraer a su mujer puede ser
por sorteo también
si uno tiene la residencia aquí hay que
apadrinar a la mujer
aunque supuestamente
es algo que es rápido pero los últimos
años ha sido bien
lento recientemente decidieron que
cualquier que ha perdido a su esposa la
va a ser menos que un año y vamos a ver
si funciona eso sí será bueno si
funciona habrá mucha discriminación en
este que están los esposos sobre todo si
no vienen en países no blancos más
países como ghana laster áfrica donde
ellos rechacen 45 por ciento los
matrimonios diciendo que son falsos
matrimonios si no son más o menos la
mitad en 10 más de los 40 por ciento y
después hay que hacer una apelación
frente a la sección de apelación de
inmigración de la comisión de
inmigración refugiados de la apelación
durar tres o cuatro años
- acá tenemos otra pregunta stewart
carlos felipe soler dice hola cree que
si alguien llega a canadá como turista y
encuentra trabajo puede cambiar su visa
allá de turista a trabajador o
inmigrante
no es imposible es muy difícil hay que
tener realmente un buen empleo
se necesita que tal vez hay que aprobar
la oferta de trabajo ya que la frontera
para aprobarla el permiso del trabajo no
es imposible pero mucho más difícil que
antes de llegar aquí y cambiar su estado
para llegar a ser una persona que
trabaja que tiene que salir del país y
regresar después cómo es el proceso
normalmente se pide permiso trabajo
antes
pero uno podría entrar aquí ubicar
empleo y después salir a buscar permiso
el trabajo y entrar
es algo que se hace todos los días
stewart en su práctica como abogado
especialista en inmigración y en
derechos humanos cuáles son los casos o
las causas que más defiende estuvo en
inmigración
yo soy
uno de los más grandes abogados de
derechos humanos internacionales aquí en
canadá represento a la gente que
llegaron aquí como refugiados pero
pidieron la protección del país
hay gente que sobre tejados que quieren
mandar la tortura la muerte en peligro
muy importante
y he hecho que el que comete contra
torturados asumidas como de derechos
humanos buscando a forzar sistema a
respetar nuestra cátedra tus manos el
derecho internacional y dar una
protección excelente
y realmente hay un problema grave de no
tener posibilidades reales aquí en
canadá corrigen los errores
pero también hay gente que han estado
aquí al frente de 35 años y cambiaron
los leyes los últimos años para hacer
mucho más fácil deportación por ejemplo
tengo un colombiano que llegó aquí en el
79 que llegó a ser presidente permanente
en 1980 de tres hijas canadienses cinco
nietos y fue condenado por fraude 2013
fraude por problema de coca
la gente a quien debía dinero lo
forzaron a hacer cosas de fraude
para pagar la deuda fue condenado
y recordaron más que seis meses de pena
stybar por cambio la del 2012 si la
condena es más que 26 meses de pena
error en deportación y nueva apelación
para la banda
clásica las deportaciones de gente negra
latino gracias 60 y que han pasado 20
años aquí que tienen niños que tienen
esposa que tienen muchos muchos
vehículos aquí y fue en colorado por
crímenes que en mis ojos no son tan
importantes
aquí en canadá realmente no locura sobre
esto la criminalidad que podemos de
importar cualquier en cualquier país y
eso
estamos frente a el sistema que está
haciendo una limpia
dulce
hay mucho miedo musculares árticas aquí
en canadá por el estado policíaco cájar
por el gobierno anterior funcionan sobre
fiestas lustrales
bueno yo les recuerdo que este es el
facebook live de radio canadá
internacional en el cual los invitamos a
ustedes allá del otro lado de la cámara
a que hagan sus preguntas estamos hoy es
miércoles 25 de enero y estamos en
compañía de stewart ex banfield abogado
especialista en inmigración y estamos
acá para contestar a sus preguntas pero
hagan sus preguntas porque no vamos a
estar acá toda la tarde en tu despacho
stewart a quienes acuden más los
inmigrantes o los refugiados
yo ayudo más a los refugiados
también muchos los emigrantes porque la
gente que han pasado 20 años aquí son
inmigrantes que no llegaron
necesariamente como refugiados
la gente que llegan allí
a la edad aquí a la edad de cinco años
que 20 años después tiene un pequeño
problema y promediando y creo que no
deportará el haití o en colombia o en
guatemala países que ya no conocen
es realmente triste porque están
quebrando familias
discriminación vergonzoso consuelo de
ciertas nacionalidades
buen ejemplo la semana pasada hablé con
la mujer con goles ya de actuar
vino aquí en el año 2000 reconocido con
una jugada bajo sus dos hijos 45 años
después unos hijos fue condenado por el
salto de asalto con un arma amenazó a
alguien con un cuchillo probar es un
paquete de cigarrillo
el joven es la derecha insultos raciales
él es su primo que está presente se
puede tomar el bus para entrar a la casa
del policía pero el bus pero de
estudiaron
de un año
no es el combinado no ha seguido en el
crimen por nada
después de 10 años fue deportado el
jueves pasado
no habla bien legal no puede escribir
francés no conocer con gobernaban los
únicos personas de familia que tienen su
vida es su mamá y su hermano que estoy
aquí el actual
está viviendo con la novia que acaba de
tener un bebé
pero aquí encara la familia niño los
esposos no importa te pueden reportarse
es un pequeño expediente crucial y
entonces eso podemos decir que son
violaciones a los derechos humanos
stewart promise y son claramente
violaciones por los derechos humanos
hay un problema extremadamente
importante lo que estoy haciendo
esta mañana yo estaba con él
que fue coronado una vez la criminal de
2010 algo que a mí no me parece muy
importante para deportarlo de sus
hermanos que quieren deportar a el que
pretender que es miembro de la pandilla
no no
pero joven simpático para el sistema que
quiere pretender que cualquier miembro
del grupo de acción criminal
exagero
que estudie su realidad
pero los locutores la verdad es
los inmigrantes tienen mucho menos que
en realidad querían hacerla que
son menos acusados son menos en la caso
menos en desempleo menos
los seguros de empleo
- divorcio
todos los indicadores sociales los
inmigrantes tienen papel mucho más
positivo que la mente que nacieron aquí
pero hay una parte del estado que quiere
pretender que los emigrantes los
refugiados sobre una amenaza por el
estado y que ellos pueden ser más
violentos o más comunes que la gente de
aquí
en la realidad si tú vives en el barrio
inmigrante va a ser barrio más seguro
que la gente entonces es simple y
llanamente discriminación a stewart
es tan simple esta discriminación sí
aunque tengo acá una pregunta
stewart de danielle camporini daniel
dice argentina vive el error de no
controlar la inmigración entran para
disfrutar de un país generoso sin
ofrecer algo a cambio cuál es cuál sería
el sistema ideal para controlar la
inmigración una pregunta de daniel campo
line de argentina
para saber exactamente lo que vamos a
hacer es muy difícil contestar en canadá
el sistema por los músculos de migrantes
por afuera que tiene algo que ver con el
mérito
creo que estos pueden ser buenos
sistemas pero también en países donde
hay inmigración tenemos que tratarlos
que llegan a nuestro país con humanidad
no queremos construir muros los
fronteras no queremos tener ciudades
bien dividida entre los que nacieron
aquí
de los que no nacieron aquí es mejor
modelo como los de canadá donde hay
una idea multinacional aquí
la apertura la emigración es por mí por
la argentina
a mí me parece igual qué
realmente hay que buscar a que toda la
primera casa y no hacer de expiración
con los países más pobres las américas
y quienes son más susceptibles stewart
de ser víctimas de abusos
de violaciones de los derechos humanos
de los inmigrantes los refugiados los
hombres las mujeres los jóvenes o todos
por igual son susceptibles cualquier que
no es blanco como yo
nuevamente
y hay un problema hay dentro las
instituciones del estado aquí en canadá
que sucede adentro la policía adentro de
la ministra de migración
ministro quizá como la figura nacional
mucho la gente nunca lo van a decir por
ellos crean que el canal pertenece a los
hijos y las hijas los colonos blancos
que ahora la gente como yo
gente como ustedes o gente negra o gente
que llegaron aquí después están aquí con
nuestro permiso pero no son realmente
canadienses como yo y eso nunca lo van a
decir esta manera de pensar
existe fuertemente dentro de las
instituciones así que realmente
- color blanco más que va a enfrentarse
como con reacciones estereotipados
ec xenofobia racismo y más q lo es pero
alguien como yo pues nos van a [ __ ] que
tenemos otra pregunta por aquí stewart
hace asistencia a posibles inmigrantes
desde sus países de origen
entonces es césar quien justamente
rodríguez de colombia que se quisiera
que me pudiera ayudar porque con los
trastes de colombia-colombia es un caso
especial porque el canadá reconoció que
había un problema grave en colombia pero
muchos años
colombia era lo que se llamaba un país
fuente
donde pudiera buscar gente en peligro y
sacarlos del país y traerlos aquí
la probabilidad de peligros
sindicalistas abogados derechos humanos
periodistas profesores concejales
municipales en ciertos departamentos del
país y el canadá sacó muchos colombianos
que estaban en peligro más o menos en
el catalán firmó el tratado de libre
cambio con colombia
y decidieron que iban a pretender que
todo fue resuelto en colombia que todos
los bonitos ahora y antes de 2011 los
que pidieron refugio vendiendo de chrome
y canadá estaban aceptado en casa del
80% y desde la mañana el rechazo fue más
potente por ciento de las personas
colombiano cambió mucho pero el hardware
quería apoyar el gobierno de uribe el
gobierno que había firmado el tratado
libre cambio con canadá
y ahora llegar de colombia como
refugiado es difícil pero igual los
colombianos son buenos inmigrantes
porque aralar porque el sistema de
picasso en colombia
produzca este acceso bueno está igual ya
para terminar el plan de inmigración de
canadá para el 2017 para este año
perdón es de admitir entre 280.000 y 320
mil nuevos inmigrantes si se puede
recibir a todos esos inmigrantes sin
problemas
yo creo que el país
hecho en ese país de emigrantes canadá
en esa ciudad donde más que limitar la
gente nacional afuera de verdad
en varios partes de canadá la economía
si es floreciente es porque tenemos los
inmigrantes aquí y realmente es un país
que ha hecho un buen trabajo de
integración de los emigrantes y yo no
creo que hay problemas con la cantidad
de
es más bien cuando uno llega aquí y
vuelven a tratar uno si van a encontrar
empleo soñado si van a encontrarla
vida mejor que uno creía hay que
entender por ejemplo muchos la gente que
llegan aquí con migrantes tienen
historias como refugiados no son
refugiados pero dejaron su país por la
corrupción por la violencia por
dictadores dictadores locos
no llegan como refugiados llegan como
inmigrantes no llegan aquí
a la paz
el estado de derecho porque tú puedes
caminar las calles uno escuchó disparos
porque habla de las mujeres semidesnudos
es con seguridad
no hay problema
depende lo que uno quiere progresar en
la vida tal vez tampoco menos dinero por
superación y decirlo como un brasileño
que llega pero quedará aquí en canadá va
a ser menos dinero hay más tenemos que
ser nosotros y tienen buena educación
van a ganar más dinero aquí aquí nos van
a secuestrar nos van a matar saliendo de
la discoteca no van a tener que tener
siempre miedo cada vez que pasen por
ciertos barrios aquí enclaves urbanos
casi no existen
entonces en
a vivir con la paz
con la seguridad con cierta democracia
eso sí vale algo
bueno y con estas últimas palabras
terminamos acá este facebook live
stewart ex banfield abogado especialista
en derechos humanos inmigración y
refugiados muchísimas gracias por tu
participación en este programa especial
y muchas gracias a todos ustedes allá
del otro lado del ojo de la cámara les
agradecemos inmensamente inmensamente su
participación y bueno pues los invitamos
a que sigan escuchando radio canadá
internacional todos los días y en
nuestro sitio internet rs y net punto
sea y todos los jueves pues el castor
cibernético por facebook live también
bueno gracias adiós felicidades